im phoenix tagesgespräch ist uns nun aus
fürth zugeschaltet professor peter
dabrock er ist der ehemalige vorsitzende
des deutschen ethikrates herr professor
druck ein einheitliches gesetz für alle
deutschen ist das etwas was sie begrüßen
guten morgen frau baltes einheitlichkeit
ist jetzt ein gebot der stunde
aber das was beschlossen worden ist ist
aus meiner sicht mutlos fantasielos und
unausgewogen und ineffektiv insofern
hätte ich mir viel mehr noch gewünscht
ich glaube das ist derzeit eher eine
symbol entscheidung und effektive
maßnahmen in harten lockdown jetzt hat
man nicht unternommen
das gesetz soll ja heute erst mal durch
den bundesrat muss man sagen und dann
morgen durch den bundesrat was wir
empfinden sie denn als mut und kraftlos
können sie das mal im detail beschreiben
bitte ja wir machen eine debatte darüber
ob er 21 oder 22 uhr als ausgangssperre
wählen debattieren ob das
verfassungsgemäß ist oder nicht und
bringen das nicht in ein verhältnis mit
blick auf die opfer die sie auch in
ihrem einspieler angesprochen haben die
die junge generation bringen muss und
ich habe den eindruck die politik wir
sind derzeit nur von leuten gemacht die
sich nicht um junge kinder um junge
studierende um jugendliche kümmern
und das alles aus dem blick nehmen und
die arbeitswelt wird nahezu komplett
nicht hinreichend berücksichtigt und das
halte ich für einen großen fehler da
haben wir viel mehr spielräume als dass
wir jetzt bei der incidents von 165 die
schulen schon schließen das heißt im
endeffekt wahrscheinlich dass viele
schülerinnen und schüler bis zu den
sommerferien keine schule mehr sehen und
das ist eine bildungskatastrophe dh sie
plädieren für mehr freiheit also heißt
schulen auf jeden fall offen lassen
bei hohen inzidenz sehen sie das ist das
problem gerade wir haben so viele fehler
in der vergangenheit gemacht wir haben
beim impfen versagt werden bei den tests
versagt wir haben bei der app versagt
und wer muss es ausbaden es sind im
wesentlichen die jungen menschen statt
dass wir sagen wir machen jetzt ein
schnitt ich bin also dafür dass wir
jetzt einen wirklich harten lockdown
machen und dass wir dann als erstes
tatsächlich die schulen öffnen unter
testbedingungen und dass wir in einer
ins priorisierung endlich die
schülerinnen und schüler nach vorne
nehmen denn die sind die ganze zeit
anderen kontakten ausgesetzt während
ältere rentner ja durchaus noch in der
lage sind ihre eigenen kontakte zu
managen um ein ganz besonderer
knackpunkt in diesem neu gefassten
gesetz sind ja die ausgangssperren
ausgangssperren dann auch für leute die
geimpft sind
wie sehen sie diesen konflikt nun das
gesetz sagt ja dass bundestag und
bundesregierung dass bundestag und
bundesrat die option haben da
tatsächlich nachzubessern
aber auch da sehe ich es so dass obwohl
ich insgesamt dafür bin dass die
beweislast dabei liegt den geimpften die
freiheits einschränkungen wieder zurück
zu dem also sie müssen sie erhalten die
kontrollmöglichkeiten so gering sind
dass derzeit wirklich umzusetzen dass
man hier aus der solidarität mit denen
die nicht geimpft sind tatsächlich noch
weiter die maßnahmen für alle aufrecht
erhalten sollte
nun blicken wir mal über das gesetz
hinaus dieses privilegien für geimpfte
ist ja wird uns auf jeden fall in
zukunft auch noch mehr beschäftigen
dieses thema was sagen sie dazu ist es
auf dauer haltbar dass wir alle gleich
behandelt werden wie sie es jetzt
angesichts des gesetzes erfordern
ich glaube das obere kriterium muss
dasjenige sein dass möglichst alle
menschen zugang zu allen in jedem fall
öffentlichen aber auch vielen privaten
an orten haben müssen und wenn wir
tatsächlich mit der impfstrategie und
auch mit der test strategie voran kommen
stellen sie sich mal vor es wäre möglich
dass jeder jeden tag getestet werden
könnte die möglichkeit nimmt ja zu
angesichts dessen dass viele geimpfte
dann gar nicht mehr getestet werden
müssten dann gibt es halt
unterschiedliche zugänge zu restaurants
zu großveranstaltungen und so könnte man
auf die art und weise die
zugangsmöglichkeit erleichtern ich
glaube dass geimpfte mittelfristig nicht
mehr die freiheits einschränkungen
aufoktroyiert werden können aber
umgekehrt müssen dann auch die nicht
geimpften zugänge zu wesentlichen
bereichen bekommen und so lange nicht
jeder deutsche ein ins angebot bekommen
hat müsste es auch so sein dass die
kosten für die testung dann jeweils auf
alle umgelegt wird das ist fair
glauben sie dass diese ausgangssperre
verfassungsfest sein wird da wir so wird
es ja klagen wohl geben
sehen sie ich habe aber natürlich die
debatten über die verfassungsgemäßheit
verfolgt habe auch verfolgt welche
debatten es darüber im
gesundheitsausschuss von den expertinnen
und experten gegeben habe ich halte das
angesichts einerseits des bisherigen
verantwortungs versagen gerade mit blick
auf die jüngere generation und mit blick
auf die anstehenden fragen für eine
marginal debatte also natürlich werden
wir dass leute geben die darüber klagen
aber wenn man sich einfach nur mal neben
sich stellt und dann sagt meine güte der
eine muss um 21 der andere um 22 uhr
ruht dann berücksichtigt welche opfer
die jüngere generation zu bringen hat
dann sollte man wirklich mal in sich
gehen und sagen was die eigene
perspektive im verhältnis zu denen der
anderen insbesondere der jüngeren
generation wertes professor peter
dabrock ganz herzlichen dank das war der
professor dabrock zum thema bundes
infektionsschutzgesetz was heute durch
den bundestag geht